yes it's a fascinating story i think
geopolitics uh because it's often
misunderstood that's why it's even more
fascinating for people
i think that um i'll start first by
talking about the early 2000s
when uh we were in a situation of high
oil prices
uh
and uh
long-term contracts uh between uh
gas prom and its uh customers in europe
and
long-term contracts which were linked to
oil prices
and at the time europe was uh i think a
little bit concerned that
it needs to rely on russia to balance
its energy demand and it was a drive uh
at the european union level uh for the
diversification of supply
um and talks about new supplies uh new
supply sources uh particularly from the
caspian uh and central asia
how does he how does russia use its
position
at that particular time the position of
higher prices the position of uh really
great uh influence in terms of gas
supplies
so first it offers sweet deals
on gas
in exchange for control over transit
pipelines
in ukraine belarus and moldova
and also
for some downstream assets or
to
countries which appear to be friendlier
than the others
also it uses its control over uh transit
routes
from central asia
to make market access hard for central
asian producers
uh at the same time it starts promoting
uh expensive
uh transit avoidance pipelines having
failed uh
to uh
somewhat uh reach mutually acceptable
agreement with transit countries it
started building expensive uh pipelines
which bypass those transit countries no
stream uh gas through that pipeline has
already is already running and
south stream
to avoid transit
through those countries
so what happens
subsequently is that obviously as you
all know the shale gas revolution in the
united states
uh great excitement
great excitement about the new gas
abundance
and
also the result of change of exit
markets for liquefied natural gas which
was supposed to go to the united states
and now is uh
going to europe
and also this affects the traditional
uh
price formula that
gasprom was using in its deals with
europe and there is a talk about
delinking
oil prices so gas prices from oil prices
and the bias six price renegotiation uh
and gas problem starts losing its market
share in europe because of this uh new
sources of gas
at the same time
one interesting development of this
period is that russia also uh ends its
uh
uh well china ends this monop against
russia's monopoly in central asia by
constructing
turkmenistan
pipeline from turkmenistan by uzbekistan
and
kazakhstan to china
which is down there
and then
and
at the same time gas chrome comes on the
increased domestic pressure from
politically connected
independent
uh
gas producers
uh to allow access to uh its expert uh
its expert monopoly and also um
to
reconsider the price uh the price system
that gas from is using in its deals with
zero
one interesting uh aspect of this hole
is
the chip and plant for gas in the united
states and uh
how it's going to play or be played
by
both in the united states both
domestically but also
internationally
if the if the gas is used domestically
it could could potentially hurt european
manufacturing and chemical industries
because of the united states will have
competitive advantage it could also
displace oil uh
so uh north american oil could flow
could start flowing uh to international
markets and become more
more volumes will be available
and as a result we'll see we may see
massive reduction of u.s dependence on
the middle east
and uh
the question will be whether the united
states will disengage militarily and
then diplomatically for the uh from that
region
and agree to be replaced with
with china
china as you can see from this slide is
a premium market
for lng
which is
no longer needed in the united states uh
china role in central asia has also
increased uh
because of pipeline projects and also
because russia is a declining power
there
and
in a way china is becoming the the
very important player in terms of
creating a new energy silk road uh from
iran to the to the far east and uh
promoting uh
potentially promoting a greater
stability in the region
okay
but what will russia will do what what
russia is likely to do in this in this
situation
um
russia is likely to choose gas volumes
over prices
um
because gas from is at the moment is
under a lot of pressure from uh
independent gas producers whose gas
production is actually lower
domestically uh it causes them it's not
doesn't cause them as much to produce
gas but also because tax contribution of
russian gas sector is only three to five
percent when it comes to the russian
budget
what it means that low gas prices uh
will change the energy mix in favor of
gas
it will promote economic recovery in
europe and demand as well but at the
same time it will undermine renewables
and lng
at the same time another interesting
aspect about those transit avoidance
pipeline which i mentioned earlier is
that russia backed pipelines nordstrom
and south stream could potentially
transport newly increased russian
volumes
uh they now make sense
that now makes sense
so those pipelines will be used for that
purpose
and the final
final slide and some final points one
final point
the rest you can put in the questions
okay does gas help or hinder making the
world a safer place obviously the
increased
availability of supplies
and increased diversity of sources is a
very important factor
and because gas producers are being uh
becoming more responsible may be being
more responsible by this new competition
and
producing consumer relations as a result
and mutual dependence
will create greater stability
at the same time some
transnational pipelines such as
turkmenistan afghanistan pakistan the
india pipeline could promote as well
integration
and stability in those regions but
one final point
is that
the battles will continue but there will
be battles based on based around markets
roots regulation technology competitive
advantage in prices and environment
and domestic politics will play the key
role in that particularly in the united
states and russia thank you thank you
very
much camille's minute is about as long
as a saint petersburg night in the
summer um but we have i have one hand up
at the front here and i think yes i
might take a few questions together but
we could take the lady at the front
first and then this gentleman here and i
can see you all as well
hi i'm katinka parish from the center
for european reform i'm going to give
you another two minutes on your last
point whether
unconventional gas will have a
stabilizing or destabilizing impact on
the international
political
environment
on the one hand you could of course
argue that if a country such as poland
has or even ukraine has significant
unconventional gas
fines
they will
russia will no longer be able to place
shenanigans with its energy policy in
its neighborhood
so the european scene looks more stable
on the other hand i'm wondering if
nations feel independent will they start
making stupid mistakes will they will
they
especially smaller countries will they
start behaving in a way that is actually
destabilizing and you could even draw
that point to china isn't a bit of
energy interdependence in the world
quite a good thing because p countries
need to be nice to each other if they
depend on each other
very nice question thank you can i just
have one behind her please the gentleman
second round
and alex ferguson from the cbi
i'm interested to hear what you think
or how likely
some
global price convergence is over the
medium term in the gas markets and also
how do you think u.s domestic politics
will affect um the ability to export
lng from the u.s so what was your part
of your first question sorry i didn't do
you think will there be a um a are we
moving towards a global gas price
convergence and if so to what extent
yes please take those two first be
reasonably concise yeah the first uh
um
the the argument that uh i think uh
uh
taking on cuttings because last point
about uh when countries become
independent i think this is something
that uh uh russian politicians has all
been complaining about saying that oh
this is
the you know the the old warsaw block
mentality those people hate us and uh
they're actually creating more problems
in a relationship with europe because
they became independent and they're
trying to play their own political games
and in gaming international i think that
um
a lot of that will depend on whether
there will be actually shale gas
development
uh in the foreseeable future
in those countries that you mentioned
because i think that russians really
have the capacity to act quite quickly
and as i said earlier there is a lot of
pressure now
particularly from
companies such as nova tech
but also from the russian oil oil
companies
particularly rosneft
to um which is
moving into gas business very actively
very actively and could potentially
uh
displace gas probe to a certain degree
within russia also
externally
so um
i don't know i think that
it's often difficult to make predictions
your question is related to 10 years 20
years 30 years 40 years but when we look
at this another important aspect to
remember about all these forecasts what
we're talking about
if you look at the
the latest they're talking about 2035
2040. so by looking about you know 20 30
years ahead
look at what
we're now in year 1920
20 30 years ahead
what has happened in the world
so i think this is this is an important
point the world is changing at a very
fast pace and i think that um a lot of
this a lot of this uh
forecasts and predictions
are just uh just a guide for us to uh to
um
you know base our decisions
used to base our decisions could you
just you know move through so you get to
the end of this yeah the next point the
next point is i'm basically saying that
um i i think it's i think it's unlikely
that they will they will play the
disabilizing role simply because i think
i think it will take them quite a while
to uh to actually reach that competitive
advantage level okay
in terms of the
the gas the gas prices
and
and also u.s decisions in america i
think it will be
um
in terms of your last point your second
question i think it's um
the years will probably use both gas
domestically but also
export it so i think there will be a
decision reached which will satisfy all
the interested parties
in the united states
when it comes when it comes to global
prices
um i'm not going to answer this question
what i suggest you do is that um on the
first of november
buy a book which is suggested by
jonathan stern
which is dealing with this very issue
which is the book is about
global oil global gas prices okay it's
it's it looks at the
different markets okay well if you tend
to buy a book that's always a good time
to move on i'd like to just take one
more brief question at the uh the back
there
and also one brief answer alan riley
city university um i think my questions
uh are simply first of all in relation
to uh the russian gas supply the um
international energy agency last year in
the world energy outlook
was talking about
the russian gas market having to replace
90 production by uh 2035. so 635 billion
cubic meters
replace uh something that the order of
magnitude in terms of investment is 730
billion dollars
in 2010
now one of the questions is can russia
actually supply that gas
especially given its kind of high north
strategy
is there cheaper gas available actually
should russia go for shale gas which
might be cheaper itself
and the other kind of bigger question
which affects gas prom and in fact all
the gas supplies is this
one of the questions which is not
debated
it's not so much the impact of cheap lng
being dumped in europe or in asia but
the effect of the shutting off of
the
coal markets in the united states
because of cheap gas and the coal being
dumped in europe in other parts of the
world and the danger is is if you get
start getting a lot of shale gas
developed in the rest of the world
they'll look for markets to dump the
coal and ironically rather than europe
leading the world into renewables
the actual future for europe
may well be
as the dumping ground for coal and this
will affect
principally the european gas suppliers
like gas problem
i think we need to sort of cut it off
there that's my my point is the coal the
issue for gas problem in part is about
its gas and its ability to actually
deliver the investment in an area of
high corruption and low investor
protection and then on another side is
the threat it faces
i think we really have to take analysis
there thank you very much i think i
partially answered your question when i
said when i talked about the role of
independent gas producers and i talked
about the role of rosneft
uh one of the reasons for the current
re-emergence of rosneft so to speak
is that rosneft potentially uh together
with uh
international companies
could
uh
as i said displace
gas control so i think just focusing on
gas from is is not is not really uh is
not really um entirely accurate i think
you should look at um
when we're talking about this uh these
issues we need to look at what the
independent producers
can do and can deliver
and again which volumes were talking
about how much how much uh you know for
russia at the moment i think the the key
dilemma is to retain this role in
european markets potentially maybe
increase it slightly and so i'm going to
just i'm really going to bring you to a
close but did you take the coal point
seriously as a sort of serious
unforeseen consequence as the gentleman
suggested
uh not really no i think it's uh
but you two can sort that one out
afterwards then thank you very much
indeed